pop
jacques demay vient d'obtenir le prix
louis delluc avec les parapluies de
cherbourg mis en musique par michel
legrand film étonnant et d'abord dans le
sens où étonnant veut dire qui étonne
qui étonne réellement c'est en effet un
film entièrement chanté en son temps et
dans une certaine mesure rené clair
avait tenté l'expérience mais pas
totalement
jacques demy à qui l'on doit lola et la
baie des anges a osé lui aller jusqu'au
bout mais les gens s'interrogent déjà
que sont ces parapluies de cherbourg une
comédie musicale un opéra quelle est
votre opinion jacques-demy bien c'est un
film entièrement chanté enfin je crois
que c'est ce qu'on peut dire le plus
précis quelle est la genèse de
l'histoire comment est-ce que cette idée
qu'il faut bien appeler insolites vous
est venue aussi décidé on sait pas trop
comment elles viennent enfin où elle ne
serait pas vous avons pas du tout non on
avait peut-être des moyens afin de les
susciter donc ça mais enfin on ne sait
pas d'où ils viennent vraiment sinon que
michel legrand est un ami enfin qu' il
aime beaucoup le cinéma et que moi
j'aime beaucoup la musique
pourquoi michel legrand la musique de
film est elle considérée comme un genre
mineur en france
je sais pas vraiment il me semble que
les musiciens eux-mêmes ne s'y
intéressent pas assez je crois que ça
vient de là pourquoi s'il ne s'y
intéressent pas
vous savez c'est très difficile de
prendre beaucoup beaucoup de temps à
s'infiltrer vraiment très profondément
dans un film je pense que ça a toujours
été considéré par les musiciens
eux-mêmes comme une chose très légère
t'offre un peu sans important est ce que
ça leur apporter de l'argent je c'est
peut-être peut-être mais pas
l'impression d'être maudit saveurs
manquait peut-être on m'a dit que la
bonne musique de film et celle qu'on
entend par quand on vole à la ola là que
non ça c'est vraiment c'est honteux je
sais pas qui dit ça fait c'est un vrai
scandale d'un axiome oui bien sûr c'est
qu'ils ne se remarque pas tout cas non
au contraire enfin je veux dire c'est
vraiment un des éléments
cinématographique vraiment c'est un des
éléments importants avec lequel on doit
compter qui à sa place qui doit venir
bien et qui doit être jeu l'iihf qui
doit avoir une espèce de présence dans
dans sa qualité
est ce que vous pensez de cette phrase
d'un poète inconnu qui désignait un de
ses poèmes défense de déposer de la
musique ou des verts c'est très joli
c'est très joli d'en-but je trouve qu'il
a tout à fait raison parce que n'importe
qui s'amusent trop à ce jeu là enfin
vraiment mais on met de la musique comme
vraiment comme souvent on dépose des
ordures louis ne fout pas pour un
musicien faire de la musique de film est
ce que c'est pas un peu compromettre son
âme
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire je
comprends pas bien se passer du temps
qu'il prend sur le temps où kippour est
consacré à faire par exemple une
symphonie
ça dépend d'abord du musicien sa dépense
ne savait pas ensuite du caractère et
puis je pense que ce n'est pas du tout
mineur où on ne s'abaisse en rien du
tout on ne savait absolument pas a écrit
une musique de film je crois d'abord
c'est très amusant si le film est
intéressant c'est amusant car c'est
difficile en est faussement libre on
pense écrire une partition mais on y lit
à tous même des contraintes et c'est au
sein de ces contraintes une fois qu'on
les a découvertes qu'il faut être libre
et je crois que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile que ça n'a l'air et de ce fait
de par sa difficulté je veux dire c'est
passionnant
à votre avis michel devant si le cinéma
avait existé de l'heure quand est-ce que
bach et beethoven musique j'en suis
certain certains poussent seulement
certains ne croyaient pas que ça aurait
pu diminuer leur chance de composer un
jour de le concerto brandebourgeois où
les symphonies non je crois pas pas du
tout pour pas du tout parce qu'elle est
un musicien qui écrit de la musique qui
si si si la musique est en lui il écrit
de la musique partout que ce soit dans
n'importe quelle forme ou styles de
musique je prends qu'il n'ya pas il n'ya
que la vie n'y a que la bonne musique
force et ça je veux dire
et vous quel est le grand pan am malgré
le labeur imposé chronométrait des
cinémas est-ce que vous pensez que vous
pouvez quand même un joueur est
équivalent de bakou de beethoven reçu un
coup sûr non ça c'est vraiment une
certitude alors mettons jeudi
l'équivalent d'un musicien classique
d'un homme dans toute la carrière une
carrière uniquement musicale sans
l'apport de personne d'autre que
musicien je sais pas faim il faudrait
avoir un
il faudrait avoir un retranchement il
faudrait aimé une solitude à ce point il
faudrait choses qui me sont absolument
impossible
[Musique]